j'ai peur comme tout le monde mais je
peux mettre ma peur de côté
alors Robert bonsoir en 20 ans vous avez
escaladé 125 gratte-ciel et monuments à
travers le monde vous êtes le Spider-Man
français
[Musique]
alors Robert rebonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
né le 7 août
1962 à Digoin en Saône-et-Loire votre
père était un ancien en chef de l'armée
de l'air à Oran devenu commercial dans
les télécoms en métropole à son arrivée
votre mère était secrétaire en Algérie
et en France elle est devenue femme au
foyer la famille s'installe à Valence
dans la Drôme et alors bizarrement
enfant vous êtes vraiment un trouillard
la nuit vous rêvez que vous tombez sans
fin dans un gouffre noir et vos cris
vous réveillent c'est peut-être aussi ce
qui m'a donné envie de faire
complètement l'opposé de de partir
justement sur le chemin verticaux c'est
fou étant enfant vous aviez perdu vide
j'étais complètement
paralysé tétanisé alors le deuxième
problème quand vous êtes en France et
vous ne mangez rien évidemment votre
développement physiologique en prend un
coup et partout vous allez vous êtes le
petit quoi je suis toujours pas très
grand alors troisième problème l'école
vous êtes gaucher et vous écrivez de
droite à gauche ça c'est encore plus
encore plus rare pour vous rééduquer on
vous attache la main gauche dans le dos
et là vous devenez parfaitement
ambidextre qui sera utile par la suite
c'est évident c'est très pratique voilà
et puis un dimanche après-midi vous
regardez un film américain
tiré du roman d'Henri Troyat la neige en
deuil c'est l'histoire de deux frères
qui entreprennent une expédition en
haute montagne vers l'épave d'un avion
l'aîné veut retrouver des rescapés
l'autre veut détrousser les cadavres et
ce film vous ouvre les yeux sur la
montagne disons que moi quand j'étais
môme je pensais au départ je voulais
faire quelque chose un petit peu dans
l'esprit de Zorro Robin des Bois alors
que là grimper des montagnes ça semblait
davantage à portée de main vers l'âge de
10 ans vous êtes envoyé en colonie de
vacances
mais évidemment avec le groupe des plus
petits et là vous décidez de vous
échapper vers le haut ça commence vous
allez vous asseoir sur le toit et vous
regardez tout ça très calmement donc
très jeune vous prenez de la hauteur
j'avais quand même envie de me prouver à
moi-même que que je pouvais faire
quelque chose
avec avec ma vie avec la verticale alors
au retour de la colo votre père a été
victime d'un infarctus du myocarde votre
mère est à son chevet à l'hôpital et là
vous devez vous débrouiller tout seul et
un jour vous partez au collège en
oubliant les clés alors on retourne vous
décidez l'escalader la façade cet étage
j'étais un petit peu dans l'urgence dans
l'obligation et puis je me suis dit
allez tu y vas je me suis lancé et puis
je suis arrivé en vie au sommet
plus jamais je me suis dit tu seras
incapable de grimper alors à 15 ans vous
grimpez les falaises du Vercors vous
faites 400 mètres quand même en solo
intégral sans la moindre sécurité vous
dites je préfère l'indépendance à
l'assurance je me sentais en sécurité de
tenir des aspérités plus ou moins
grosses et puis finalement ne plus
réellement avoir confiance au matériel
alors votre premier accident en fait
vous faites du ski hors-piste vous
tombez sur une plaque de glace à
l'hôpital les toubibs vous révèle que
vous êtes épileptique et le mec vous dit
que l'escalade pouvait dire adieu c'est
fini bon c'est ça c'est pas une très
bonne nouvelle donc je savais pas
exactement ce que c'était l'épilepsie
mais bon fallait essayer de faire avec
mais rien ne vous arrête en 1982 vous
décidez de grimper la mythique falaise
ardéchoise l'abominable homme des doigts
en solo intégrale donc c'est à dire son
corde ce n'est pas un sport vous dites
c'est une ascèse une ascèse qui m'est
devenue vitale
ouais c'est devenu je vais dire je me
suis tellement ambattu je veux dire de
l'âge de du petit gamin que j'étais qui
avait peur de tout qui avait peur du
vide et finalement de me retrouver là
c'est devenu un mode de vie c'est c'est
toute ma vie en fait vous faites une
chute de 20 mètres vous tombez peut-être
première sur une dalle rocheuse le bilan
c'est une semaine de coma la peau
déchirée les veines tranchées les os du
bassin des genoux des coudes des
poignets en miettes et le toubibouillis
dans votre cas on ne parle pas de
fracture mais de fracas osseux quand
même la première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit si je lui ai demandé
quand est-ce que je pourrais regrimper
effectivement quelques semaines plus
tard vous signez une décharge pour
quitter l'hôpital et rentrer chez vous
vous avez décidé de reprendre l'escalade
alors vous installez une barre de
traction dans le chambre d'une porte et
bien tout vous faites 700 tractions en
une heure et en deux ans vous devenez
une sorte de surhum mais avec trois
doigts hors d'usage quand même c'est
exact à cause d'une air cubital
sectionnée votre corps est devenu si
puissant que vous arrivez à faire des
tractions avec un seul doigt
[Musique]
alors là dessus vous avez des
étourdissements vous allez voir un ORL
qui vous dit votre accident vous a
détruit l'oreille interne et vous allez
avoir de violents vertiges toutes votre
vie vous avez trouvé une antidote un
mantra le mantra c'est de répéter sans
cesse j'ai confiance en moi et je
réussis tout ce que j'entreprends j'ai
confiance en moi et je réussis tout ce
que j'entreprends j'ai confiance en moi
et je réussis tout ce que j'entreprends
apparemment ça marche ça a l'air de
marcher en 1986 donc vous escaladez
l'abominable homme des doigts là vous
étiez tombé en solo intégral et en 94
vous escaladez la tour citigroupe à
Chicago
187 mètres alors première difficulté
monter le plus rapidement possible
pendant les 60 premiers mètres
parce que 60 mètres c'est la hauteur
maximum d'une échelle de pompiers donc
une fois que vous êtes au dessus de 60
mètres ils peuvent plus vous rattraper
il leur faut à peu près deux minutes tu
as deux minutes pour être à 60 mètres
deuxième difficulté la surface vitrée
parce que là c'est pas de la roche il y
a pas de spiritisme ça glisse vous
accrochez où les cadres qui a autour des
vitres parfois il y a des fissures
parfois il y a pas il y a pas grand
chose il y a juste des petites aspérités
des petites réglettes donc vous êtes
déjà arrivé quand vous montez à un
moment de plus rien trouver pour vous
accrocher non parce qu'en fait je fais
des repérages au préalable j'utilise les
jumelles ou alors je vais dans des
bâtiments voisins j'essaye de d'observer
correctement mais là vous découvrez une
autre adrénaline une fois que vous êtes
en haut vous découvrez la jungle d'acier
de verre avec les gratte-ciel qui
jaillissent comme ça il y a un terrain
de jeu potentiel qui s'offre et en fait
on retrouve partout le Mexico City en
par les États-Unis ou la Chine entre
1994 et 2015 vous escaladez 125
gratte-ciel et monuments dans le monde
Guinness Book évidemment parmi elles le
Golden Gate à San Francisco 227 m
l'obélisque de la Concorde la tour
Montparnasse de 109 mètres le Taipei
la tour Ariane 152 mètres la tour First
la défense 231 mètres et la plus haute
le Burj Khalifa ha Dubaï
828 la ce qui est drôle c'est que quand
les flics vous vous arrêtent vous
retrouverez en tôle et là en fait vous
snobez les autres prisonniers parce que
vous faites 40 pompes sur un bras dans
tous les cas ils sont évidemment très
admiratifs et on vous appelle little
Schwartz il y a les muscles c'est pas
c'est pas la taille mais ça fonctionne
alors quand on vous parle de la peur
vous dites oui effectivement j'ai peur
mais je tire mon plaisir de dominer
cette peur de faire abstraction de la
chute c'est ça votre force en fait ce
que je fais c'est avant tout mental
après je mets mon corps au service de
mes envies finalement j'ai peur comme
tout le monde mais je peux mettre ma
peur de côté c'est la grande différence
avec nous
alors c'est extraordinaire
c'est que la sécurité sociale vous
considère comme un valide à
66%, mais évidemment pour toucher cette
pension d'invalidité il faut être sans
activité et être sans activité c'est pas
possible pour Spider-Man c'est
totalement impossible donc j'ai toujours
préféré ne pas avoir d'argent alloué par
le gouvernement français et vivre de ma
passion et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu